welcome to database def doc I'm your
host - kasi developer advocate for data
studio in this video we'll discuss how
you can share and publish your connector
let's get started let's say you have
just developed your first community
connector you're conscious about your
help and track your daily activities so
you've created a Google fit connector to
track your Google feed data in data
studio you have tested the functionality
added healthful error messages and
created separate testing and production
deployments so the connector is good to
go at this point that connector can be
used only on your account since you have
not shared it with others when a user
uses a community connector under the
hood data studio is executing functions
from the connector script on the user's
behalf therefore the users account must
have read access to the script otherwise
status to do cannot execute the script
if you're working a team to develop the
connector or what if you trusted users
to try out the connector you must
provide read access to your connector
strip to these users but what if you
want to share the country with everyone
you found your google fit connector to
be very helpful and you think others can
also benefit from it for that the first
step would be to share your Apps Script
project by link head over to that script
environment open your project hit the
share button on the top right and click
on get shareable link make sure that the
option anyone with the link and view is
visible if you're in a g-suit
organization this option might not be
available based on in your
administrative settings in this specific
case you can either talk to your g-suit
admin to enable this option or copy of a
via strip to a non restricted account
like a gmail account at this point all
users have read access to your script
keep in mind that unless a user has the
exact link to your app strip project
they will not be able to view the code
in absolute environment
now to share the connector with other
users you also need to get the correct
deployment link open your connector in
Apps Script environment click on publish
from the menu and select apply from
manifest this will show you a list of
all deployments for your connector we
will cover versioning and deployments in
a separate video
from this interface copy the appropriate
deployment link and share it with others
you can share the link through email
social media or your own blog anyone who
goes to this deployment link will be
able to use your connector configure it
connect to their own Google feed data
and create their own separate dashboards
that's pretty neat you can get greater
visibility for your connector by
publishing it to the data Studio
connector gallery if the connector gets
published all data studio users will be
able to view the connector while
exploring or searching through the
gallery you can publish your connector
in two ways either as a Parker connector
or as an open-source connector if you
publish as a partner connector you will
need to support and deploy and maintain
the connector yourself you can follow
the partner connector guidelines and
submit a review request to get started
if the connector passes the review it'll
be included in the gallery as a partner
connector publishing in this way helps
you and your organization to get more
exposure add your own branding and also
monetize your connector on the other
hand you can publish as an open-source
connector in that case the connector is
deployed by the data studio devrel team
and supported by the community you can
start the process by submitting a pull
request to our repository link is in the
description once the pull request is
approved your connector will be
showcased in the gallery as an
open-source connector this is a great
way for you to showcase your code
publishing your connector helps to get
better visibility reach a bigger
audience and provide better value to
your existing users you also become
eligible to be considered for
promotional activities so we recommend
that if you build a connector you should
publish it
however keep in mind that you don't have
to publish to share your connector with
others you can share by link even
without publishing and then just give
the deployment URL to users hopefully
you find this sharing and publishing
overview for community collectors useful
you can always go to our developer site
at developers.google.com/live ater
studio for more information if you like
this video stay tuned on the GCP channel
for more data store your content thanks
for watching
[Music]
[Applause]